hello there i'm aj aonuma producer of
the legend of zelda series
i'm sure a lot of you saw me and thought
there might be news about the sequel to
the legend of zelda breath of the wild
game
unfortunately we don't have anything to
share right now
we apologize development is proceeding
smoothly and we should be able to bring
you some new information this year
for now we'll have to ask you to wait
just a bit longer
while you're all waiting however this
legend of zelda game will be coming to
nintendo switch
please take a look
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
what you've just seen is the legend of
zelda skyward sword hd
this game originally released in 2011 on
the wii console and now it's coming to
nintendo switch
the legend of zelda skyward sword
featured a control scheme
in which players would use the wii
remote plus controller as a sword
and the nunchuck controller as a shield
with the increased processing power of
the nintendo switch system
the controls here are smoother and even
more intuitive
and we've recreated the controls for the
sword and the shield here by having the
player hold two joy-con controllers
the joy-con controller in your right
hand is the sword
swing it to have link swing his sword in
the game
the joy con controller in your left hand
is the shield by lifting the controller
you can raise the shield to block enemy
attacks
you can perform other actions like using
both controllers to wield a bow and
arrow
these physical movements add a sense of
urgency and tension to combat
but we've also made it possible to play
the game with button controls to ensure
it can be played in handheld mode or on
the nintendo switch light system
after mulling over how to assign
different gameplay elements to different
buttons
we decided to apply the sword motions to
tilting the right control stick
[Music]
tilt the stick down when you want to
swing the sword downward
to swing to the right to the left
or diagonally just tilt the stick in the
respective direction
here's something else we've been working
on specially designed joy-con
controllers
the right joy-con controller is themed
after the master sword while the left
features a hylian shield motif
the legend of zelda skyward sword as the
game depicting the earliest story in the
legend of zelda timeline
details the events around the creation
of the master sword itself
[Music]
we hope that people who played the
original game on wii and those playing
it for the first time will enjoy
discovering the origins of the legend of
zelda
[Music]
the legend of zelda skyward sword hd
launches july 16th
following this nintendo direct you'll be
able to pre-order the game on nintendo
eshop
and the specially designed joy-con
controllers will launch on the game's
release date at your local retailers
many of you may already know this but
the legend of zelda skyward sword was
the last original console game prior to
the legend of zelda breath of the wild
game and it was still following the
established conventions of the legend of
zelda however it gave a glimpse into
many features and innovations that would
eventually be adopted in the legend of
zelda breath of the wild
using the sail cloth to descend in
mid-air a stamina gauge that depleted as
you scaled walls with vines or ran
even the concept of collecting items to
upgrade gear
i hope those of you who've played the
legend of zelda breath of the wild will
give this game a try as well
[Music]
please look forward to the legend of
zelda skyward sword hd
yes